so the editor contacted me and asked me
to come up with an origami fold that was
representative of the volume and issue
number 1607 eventually we settled on
folding the actual digits 16 and those
seven and to make it interesting in an
origami challenge and try to fold all
four digits from a single sheet of paper
so they're going to get a page and it'll
look like this
first thing we'll do is just cut it out
along the black lines so that you have
just to pay a pattern with red and blue
lines the red lines our Mountain folds
those are folds that's shaped like this
the blue lines are Valley folds folds a
shape like this so the first thing
you'll do is go through this pattern and
make a crease where every line is so for
example here's a red line and so you'll
make a mountain fold that is you fold
the paper away from itself on that line
and then and then you open it out and
then I'll make a valley fold or a valley
fold off to set it down on the table and
and make that crease and then open it
out and you notice I only made the fold
up to where it ends it didn't go all the
way across and you'll go through the
whole page and make all of those folds
to make the red ones as mountains the
Blues as valleys when you've completely
covered that up then you can start
trying to bring all those folds together
as a kind of a hint to start I found
when I folded it that if I tried to make
the folds that created the six first
then you can move down to seven and make
the folds that create the zero and then
make the folds to create the one so you
kind of work your way in a circle it
won't lie completely flat until you've
got all the creases in place so it'll be
sort of rumpled and three-dimensional
the kind of the keys to all of these is
to get the corners there are these
valley folds that run down the corners
and if you don't get those in first you
can't create the raised lines that
create it so I'd say sort of focus on
getting the folds
to find the corners in the place but
really you have to bring all the folds
together more or less at once
you